yeah welcome to this video playing vatta
from Argentina down let's go for our
Kings gambit again I recently had a
king's gambit and he has widened and won
a funny game hmm yeah I have no idea
Queen eater oh wait I can play this one
do you five I can take so okay but I
cannot play h3 here right so probably
deform nastily can give this check hmm
yeah the Kings gambit I need to if I
employ this I really need to think for a
moment he and there because with the
price of a mistake is usually really
really high in this opening you can
easily lose in such a short number of
moose put them by playing on Bishop h4
king of one night f2 may be cool anyone
this playable okay he doesn't go for
that
yeah it's not clear what my compensation
is for the poor probably there isn't any
okay but i can develop at least 94 maybe
i can get the pawn bag this is often the
positive thing about about bad positions
you sometimes have a really clear goal
like i need to get my ball back or let's
say you have a bad piece somewhere and
you're not in good shape you know okay i
need to get rid of this bad piece
sometimes help you helps you in in
finding a plan simply because it is so
apparent what what is wrong okay h3y am
but he wants to return anyway maybe i
can check the the bishop get this to get
this piece k we retreats
oh this is surprising I was really a
more concerned about Knight Returns we
came and it's also i don't know this
could be dangerous i'm on f7 very very
often and I've got queen age five coming
wow isn't this very good for white by
the Kings gambit I need to play this
more often yeah the thing about those
some kind of this kind of very
aggressive openings as if it if it works
it really works and you you often just
win yeah this wins the Queen right I
mean age six Bishop e6 takes e6 Queen g6
and made on age 70 he needs to need to
give the Queen
let all winds basically
Queen h7 should be really deadly he can
maybe sec the Queen for two pieces when
I keep attacking Queen 87 mate he can
Quinn play Queen g5
yeah Queen g54 else
other moves should should be just made I
mean queen h them what is there to
consider
curious I really don't know what what
other moves than taking on g5 I mean
okay taking on g fibers it's very close
to just giving up but what else look f 6
Go Go quit h 7 h a g7 and win the house
look f5 I can take it six it's really no
move black resins it needs to give the
Queen and play with the Queen down yeah
93 was a was terrible he needs to
retreat to have six and it's it's a
position where black it's upon up it's
not super clear but yeah white is a born
down and the compensation is very
questionable after 93 however I think
why just wins ok e 2 e 2 is a good map
not great offense buddy to try to
distract ya still I can take when I was
a bit worried about that but it's it's
it's no problem now it's just the end on
f7 so plus 10 according to complete yeah
it got very very dangerous sunday but if
he retreats to to have six I can change
I can try what that was my plan I can
tell you what my plan was I wanted to
play this or some other move to prevent
Queen check but in fact you can take
here yeah comes the side I didn't see
change it the idea yeah Kate was a
preposition it's a king's gambit after
all kids it's not necessarily so bad
like what I got in the game but it's
it's simply risky and I don't know much
about it alright thanks for watching